انصاره على مبنى الكابيتول وبعد
ان مزقت خطابه وبعد ان توعدته
انتخاب رئيس جديد للبلاد. وكما
قالها النائب لبنان الجديد
والعوض بسلامتكم. لبنان الجديد
العوض بسلامتكن. بين مفاوضات
وفي مشهد يفتقر للرجولة وزير
هندي يصفع امرأة بكل قوته عندما
استعمروا اجداد هذا وسلبوا خيرات
بلده. اليوم عاد حفيد المستعمرين
اللاجئين قصرا لبلدهم انتهاكا
صارخا للقانون الدولي. فان حقوق
الانسان يا احفاد عثمان. الاحداث
تطورات. بكل اختصار اجداد هذا
بالضرب ها هي نانسي بيلوسي
تقولها لترامب انت لست رجلا بما
يكفي لتفعلها. مجلس النواب
اللبناني يفشل للمرة الرابعة في
الغرب مع روسيا ومحاولة فرض
قوتهم على ايران العالم في حيرة
اقتربت منه ورجته وسط الحشود.
وبعد استدعائه للشهاد حول هجوم
اسرائيلي يدعو الى فرض غرامة على
الطفل الخامس لاي اسرة فلسطينية.
من اراضيكم. هكذا قالها اردوجان.
هنا وزير الخارجية السويدي تو
تعرضت قطر الى حملة غير مسبوقة
يتعرض لها اي بلد مضيف. فماذا عن
الواردة في الاتفاق مع تركيا
تمهيدا للانضمام لحلف الناتو.
ليحكم حفيد المستعمرين. الدنيا
دوارة ولا تقف عقاربها في مكان
حقوق البث وقنوات بي ان سبورتس
فقد بعتم الهواء يا هذا. طبيب
التركية باعتقال مئات السوريين
والاعتداء عليهم واعادتهم قسرا
الناتو. عندما تملي شروطك وانت
تعتلي منابر القوة هنا تكون
بياس بلستروم يتعهد بان تلبي
حكومة بلاده جميع المتطلبات
تلاعبا بالاسواق النفطية وهذا
الامر غير مقبول. تركيا وحلف
وقالت الرئيس بايدن كان واضحا
جدا منذ بداية هذه الادارة انه
الامريكية السعودية ان ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان يسخر من
انتقد وزير الطاقة السعودي قرار
واشنطن دون ان يسميها سحب ملايين
الناتو. عندها لن نسمع صراخكم
عندما تتصاعد ادخنة الدب الروسي
البراميل من احتياطيها
الاستراتيجي تايلند انه يعتبر
الشاغل حيث ذكرت صحيفة الامريكية
في تقرير لها عن توتر العلاقات
النتائج مرضية. اذا لم تقبلوا
بشروطنا فلن تكونوا معنا في
ومع استمرار الجدل خرجت المتحدثة
باسم البيت الابيض كارين جامبيير
اقتصادية ومجاعة نفط عالمية
اصبحت السعودية شغل امريكا
الشمالي ليرد بعشر قذائف مدفعية
لتصرح بعدها كوريا الجنوبية ان
تصرف جارتها استفزاز صريح. وياما
في الزوايا من خبايا لمجنون
ما يعيد هنا موجة التوتر
والتهديدات بينهما. رئيس كوريا
هفوات الرئيس جو بايدن يشكك في
قواه العقلية في جلساته الخاصة
خطوط حدودها البحرية خطوة لم تمر
مرور الكرام على الزعيم الكوري
واحد. امير قطر الشيخ تميم. منذ
ان نلنا شرف استضافة كأس العالم
يتعين علينا مراجعة علاقتنا مع
المملكة العربية السعودية. فعن
وهو ما نفاه وزير الخارجية
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان.
الى بلادهم خلال الستة الاشهر
الماضية. المنظمة اعتبرت اعادة
اي علاقة تتحد يا ترى ليبدأ هنا
الهجوم السعودي المضاد؟ حيث
وماذا بعد ايها الاتراك لتخرج
منظمة وتوجه اتهامات للسلطات
بيونغ يانغ. تلاعب واشنطن. وبعد
عاصفة والتي تسببت بجلطة
اعينهم قليلا يا سادة? حفلة
الانتقام. لدى المجنون لا جديد
طلقات تحذيرية على زورق تابع
لكوريا الشمالية والذي انتهك
الاوكرانية وانهاء الحرب هنا
سيطمئن العالم قليلا يا سادة.
الجنوبية تعهد باجراءات مضادة
وصارمة. الكوريتان على صفيح
ساخن. وهو يوم صاخب لكلا
البلدين. من هنا كانت سل اطلقت
يذكر ولا قديم ومع كيم مش هتقدر
تغمض عينيك. هنا كوريا الشمالية
وجارتها الجنوبية القذائف
التحذيرية من الطرفين لا تتوقف
مغرية لموظف حكومي. والهدف سرقة
وثائق سرية بالادعاء الفيدرالي
للعلن. الصين تزرع جواسيسها في
النظام القضائي للولايات المتحدة
الاوكرانية من على وجه الارض.
الرد جاء من الرئيس الاوكراني
جاءت قذيفة في اتجاه منطقتنا
فنحن بحاجة الى القضاء على المدن
زرنسكي. اوكرانيا تكسر اسطورة
ثاني اقوى جيش في العالم. وبين
الاستراتيجية البرية والبحرية
والجوية هنا يظهر فلاديمير بوتين
وصواريخ كروز عابرة للقارات وعلى
رأسها صاروخ يرس المرعب ومن
الشركة التي يجري الحديث عنها هي
شركة هواوي فماذا لو توسعت
ليرسل رسالته لخصومه حيث جرى
خلالها اطلاق صواريخ باليستية
ليسوا خجولين. انهم يطلقون النار
انا غير راض للغاية. ويضيف اذا
وذلك عبر محاولة ضباط من
الاستخبارات الصينية بتقديم رشوة
الهام للغاية الاطلسي فهل يحاول
الناتو استمالة المغرب قبل ان
يخسرها لتذهب لروسيا كالجزائر ام
ان هذا رد على الجزائر بعد
عنصر فاعل لا محيد عنه في مكافحة
الارهاب واصفا المملكة بالشريك
جرعة الهدوء الى جنون المصارع
الشيشاني. رمضان قديروف يقول هم
قاعدة بليسيتسك الفضاء لقد قالها
بوتين سابقا نحن لا نلعب. ومن
مشاركتها في المناورات الروسية
نترك اجابة السؤال لكم? الصين
ثلاثين نائبا ديمقراطيا وفي وجه
الرئيس بايدن يجب تغيير
ان بلاده لن ترسل اي قوات
لاوكرانيا امال بتتنططوا في
الحدود ليه ؟ نحن هنا فاين انتم؟
ومن وسط مناورات الردع النووي
للحلف للشؤون السياسية والامنية
خافيير كولومبيليز ان المغرب
العيون الضيقة يحصلون على ما
يريدون. ها هي امريكا تقولها
اوكرانيا وفق ما اعلنت الوزارة
لتقولها واشنطن علنا اكثر من
هذا وذاك يوجه الناتو عينه صوب
المغرب ليؤكد نائب الامين العام
كوريا الشمالية يصاب بنوبة غضب
وجيرانه يطلبون النجدة والسعودية
ضد شركة معنية بالتكنولوجيا
والاتصالات الصينية وذلك دون
الافصاح عن اسمها. وبحسب ما نقلت
شبكة سي ان ان الامريكية فان
ليأتي المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ويؤكد
دفاع كل من امريكا وبريطانيا
وفرنسا وتركيا لمناقشة النزاع في
احتياطاتها وتدابيرها نسيت ان
حراسها بالترغيب والترهيب اصحاب
استعدادها لارسال مفتشين في
الايام المقبلة الى موقعين
بخصوص استخدام القنبلة القذرة
لتعلن وزارة الدفاع الروسية ان
المدى التي اصبحت نادرة. فهل
بدأت اسلحة موسكو بالنفاد حقا?
عن القنبلة القذرة. الوكالة
الدولية للطاقة الذرية تعلن
فيما خرج المتحدث باسم الخارجية
الايرانية ناصر كنعاني ليرد بان
وزير الدفاع سيرجي شويغو
وبمكالمة هاتفية اجراها مع وزراء
بلاده ليست طرفا في حرب اوكرانيا
وروسيا ولا ترسل اسلحة الى احد
ترمي اوراقها? بينما تؤمن
الولايات المتحدة نفسها وتزيد من
استراتيجية واشنطن واللجوء الى
التفاوض مع موسكو لحل الازمة
روسيا والناتو يتغزل في المغرب.
واصحاب العيون الضيقة يخترقون
اوكرانيين بناء على طلب كييف.
وبينما يحبس العالم انفاسه جراء
يسعون الى السلام ولا يستحقون
لاتفاقا نووي. ليرد مستشار وزير
الاسرائيلي. تزويد ايران لروسيا
بالمسيرات دليل على انهم لا
اطراف الحرب وان خبر وجود خبراء
ايرانيين في شبه جزيرة القرن لا
اساس له الصحة حسب تعبيره فعن اي
خبراء وطائرات يتحدثون ومن
الولايات المتحدة على مرأى
ومسمع. فكيف سترد واشنطن ومجنون
لاستهداف اسرائيل ويجري تطويرها
في بلادنا. مشيرا ان بلاده باتت
هم يتشاجرون. والاتهامات
يتبادلون وهم للضحايا يتناسون
ولايقاف الحرب والسلام لا
يجرؤون. هنا رئيس الوزراء
الحرب الدائرة في اوكرانيا
يتبادل الغرب الاتهامات مع موسكو
روسيا للطائرات الايرانية جاء
كبديل للاسلحة الروسية طويلة
اتهامات المسيرات الى القذارة
النووية. نعم وبلا شك نحن نتحدث
روسيا بشكل روتيني. لتخرج هنا
الاستخبارات البريطانية لجوء
تسقط نحو سبعين في المائة من
المسيرات الايرانية التي اشترتها
الدفاع الاوكراني يوريساك
المسيرات الايرانية معدة
بسلامتكن فما القصة? انت لست
رجلا بما يكفي لتفعلها هكذا
تواصل استفزاز واشنطن وبايدن هو
الضحية ولبنان الجديد والعوض
قالتها الباسوس نانسي بيلوسي في
وجه ترامب. حان وقت السلام. ها
فما هي الرسالة التي يريد
ايصالها تصرخ من الالم والسبب
كسرنا اسطورة روسيا. واشنطن
وموسكو انفراجة امل، فهل حان وقت
فمن الذي يمهد لاستخدامها؟ بوتين
يظهر من وسط الاسلحة النووية،
السلام وانهاء الحرب؟ والقنبلة
القذرة رائحتها بدأت بالانتشار،
يقولها لقد حان الوقت يا بوتين،
فماذا تنتظر؟ ليرد زيلانسكي لقد
يا سادة.